you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 News Now
construction is going to be one of those
outdoor jobs that is probably not going
to be any fun over the next couple of
days in fact some things may be
postponed we are rocking and rolling
with clouds and sunshine Valley
temperatures that have made it into the
pretty mild 70s at noon for many
locations some 60s out on the west side
somewhere in 62 Red Rock 64. 49 up at
Kyle Canyon and 70s in Boulder City with
near 70s in Pahrump this afternoon just
to show you some of these wind gusts I
mean everybody's feeling at least some
of this wind Kyle Canyon mountain spring
Summit between Pahrump and Las Vegas
both near 50 mile an hour winds and
North Las Vegas near 40 Nellis the same
a lot of neighborhoods have felt gusts
30 to 35 miles an hour the higher
elevations have had a stronger wind
gusts than 50 miles an hour just want to
get you through your day tomorrow it's
election day and you better grab a
jacket and an umbrella it is going to be
windy again for Tuesday temperatures are
going to be cooler I don't think we're
going to make it to the 70s tomorrow 57
at 7 A.M when the polls open 63 at 10
A.M if you're using your lunch hour to
vote tomorrow 68 chances of rain pretty
good through the day tomorrow and windy
with mid to low 60s as we get through
the late afternoon until the polls close
at 7 pm so it is just give yourself more
time and plan on taking maybe a little
bit longer cold air with a winter like
system is bringing rain and snow into
California the Sierra is getting a lot
of snow already even some snow in
Western Nevada Reno had snow on the
streets in the mountains earlier today
and especially in the highways i-50 and
as Highway 50 and Interstate 80. we are
windy and we've got the clouds so far
and wind advisories already in effect in
our local mountains where we've been
seeing those extra strong gusts but
starting tomorrow at noon until
Wednesday 4 a.m we'll start to feel
those winds a little stronger with wind
advisories for all of the lower
elevations 8 to 16 inches of snow is
possible with this winter storm in our
local mountains with winter storm watch
that starts tomorrow and goes all the
way until early Wednesday morning we're
looking at maybe mid 70s now because
they're only a few degrees away from
that Gusty winds and by tonight we're
still going to have clouds around as the
system approaches but I just wanted to
remind you it is a total lunar eclipse
in the overnight hours it all begins at
1am it Maxes Prime right around 2 15 to
2 45 a.m if you want to get out there
and take a look it's a blood total blood
moon total full eclipse so won't see
another one until 2025. cooler 60s
chances of rain Tuesday and Wednesday
and we drop to the 50s John it's going
to be chilly all the way through
Veterans Day even after the rain ends
look at those cool temperatures mornings
back into the 30s we can see up to a
half an inch of rain maybe more this
week we can use it for sure